it is seven o'clock good to have you
with us this morning the foreign
secretary liz truss is calling for the
uk and other western powers to provide
fighter jets to ukraine in a speech this
evening she'll say that the west must be
prepared for the long haul and warned
that vladimir putin wins we that is all
of us would never feel safe again for
its part russia is warning britain of an
immediate proportional response if it
continues what the kremlin calls the
direct provocation of ukraine to strike
targets inside russia in the next few
minutes we'll ask the justice secretary
dominic wrap what that might mean it is
wednesday the 27th
sky news reports from a village on the
front line as it comes under fire from
russian forces
again
this place has come under attack
they've managed to get everybody out of
the village
but we need to leave now too
turning off the taps right now gas
supplies to poland are cut off by russia
because they refused to pay in rubles
also ahead myanmar's ousted democratic
leader onsen tsuchi sentenced to a
further five years in prison by the
military
thus the legal requirement for annual
mots could be axed as part of government
plans to tackle the cost of living
crisis
but will it make driving more dangerous
i'm in drive andover to find out if
drivers here give the plan the green
light
and you'll die a fat lonely old man the
latest from the defamation trial between
johnny depp and amber hart
also ahead on the program
making trafalgar square even wilder i'll
be speaking to ray mears about plans to
transform one of london's most iconic
landmarks
and i'll later be joined by one of team
gd's olympic stars the champion bmx
racer bethany schriever who was part of
the hat-trick british women recognized
at the prestigious glorious world sports
awards
[Music]
morning all heavy weapons tanks and
planes the foreign secretary is urging
western countries to do much more to
support ukraine in a speech this evening
she'll say that the west must be
prepared for the long haul and double
down on our support russia has already
accused nato of waging a proxy war and
has warned britain that what it calls
direct provocation of ukraine will lead
to an immediate proportionate response
we'll have more than that in just a
moment uh but first we have a report
from the very front line in eastern
ukraine
sky news team traveled to the village of
alex and drivka and were there when it
came under attack from russian forces
less than a mile away from there sky's
alex rossi reports
along forest roads and across farmland
ukrainian forces race to fortify the
donbass
every day brings new fighting
with russian artillery hitting the small
villages on the front line
black smolders on the horizon
eventually we reach alexandrevka
russian forces are about two kilometers
away and it's now almost deserted
as we follow the soldier tells us to use
the trees as cover
there are drones above he wants and
standing in the open here can get you
killed
this is where it landed today
the smoke over there you can see
the places that are being shelled at the
moment and then one just landed over
here
he shows us a farm it's too dangerous to
go further he says it's just been struck
the family escaped but it soon comes
under attack again
[Music]
let's go let's
everyone go yeah everyone's good
get up guys let's go
well again
this place has come under attack they've
managed to get everybody out of the
village
but we need to leave now too
millions of ukrainians have been
displaced or trapped by this conflict
the front lines are shifting here all
the time
and as russian forces advance many
villages like this one are now in the
firing line
nearby this group of medics takes a
break behind the front line
a chance to grab rest and share food
under the cover of the woodlands
every day is difficult treating comrades
but they are convinced putin's forces
can be defeated
[Music]
showing that
this war is now entering its third month
and as ukraine reinforces its army in
the east with fresh soldiers and new
weapons
its army knows the next few weeks will
be decisive
uh well of course alex rossi are
reporting they're from the donbass we
are hoping to speak to alex just a
little bit later this morning we will
keep our fingers crossed at that we can
well let's speak now uh about mots one
of those terrible things that we all
have to go through once a year but of
course as part of the uh government's
cash the government's cost of living
crisis cabinet yesterday grant shaps
came up with well what some people i
think will say it's quite a decent idea
uh the government could be axing that
annual requirement for mots as part of
their plans let's
bring in uh madeleine radcliffe who's
speaking to us today from uh down in
dover outside well outside an mlt center
appropriately enough what is the
thinking behind this i mean i can't
remember how much i paid the last time i
went for an mot but it wasn't you know
600 700 pounds which is what my energy
bill's going up by
no the legal limit for um for an mot is
55 pounds for your normal family car um
although garages can charge less if they
want and it's every year if you've got a
car over three years old so it's not a
huge drain on household finances but the
context of this is obviously the
government
feeling the pressure on the cost of
living crisis boris johnson head of
cabinet yesterday put the call out to
all his ministers and ministers and said
find a way to make um
save families money and and try and
alleviate this pressure this cost of
living um pressure on them but without
spending more money so ministers were
looking for small tweaks they could make
which might shave pounds here and there
of household bills and this is what the
transport secretary grant chapters come
up with so instead of paying your 55
pounds for a car mot every year it would
be every two years
and and that might be a good saving but
there are questions this raises for a
start if your car is serviced less
regularly and drives less efficiently
you're going to end up paying more for
fuel which is of course very expensive
at the moment and the aaa have pointed
out their head of road policy jack
cousins have pointed out that while it
might save money and be well-intentioned
uh drivers could end up facing far
higher bills for repairs in between
those mots besides the fact that there
are road safety concerns and indeed
it could it could put jobs in in garages
like this at risk if people are required
to do these tests less often the aa also
pointed out that it was only recently
that the government were looking at
making mots bi-annual instead and they
moved away from that idea because of
road safety fears and polling at the
time done by the aaa suggested that the
vast majority of drivers actually
support this annual check-up for their
cars it makes them feel safer and more
secure so whether the cost of living
crisis has actually changed drivers
minds on this we'll see the next step
which though is this will be considered
by uh boris johnson as to whether to put
make this a put this into practice
madeline thanks very much indeed
uh we saw his report from the eastern
ukraine just a couple of moments ago
let's speak now to to the reporter uh
head of the team responsible alex rossi
joining us uh from kramertosk in the
east of the country this morning good to
see you alex uh some incredible
reporting some very very scary scenes
for you and the team but but the one
takeaway from your report this morning
those that you are with on ukrainian
side feel they can defeat vladimir putin
in the east
good morning uh neil yeah i mean the
yeah you're quite right that the
takeaway from all of this is that the
russian advance
is starting it's fairly slow we've had
some uh information in the last couple
of hours that the village that we were
in alexandrevka has now been taken by
russian forces we saw the beginning of
that attack the ukrainian soldiers there
that we spoke to they managed to
evacuate those places now there is a
patchwork of these small farming type
villages across the line of contact at
the moment which is moving
south from those russian positions they
did manage to get people out
but it is moving forward but that said
the russians are at risk
from
a counter-attack a ukrainian
counter-attack we saw a large number
of ukrainian soldiers we also saw quite
a lot of heavy weaponry
as well and they are very confident that
they can win this war
particularly of course with the support
that they are getting
many countries around the world are now
sending in heavy weapons to this area
to try to stop that russian invasion uh
in the in its tracks now they are also
boys because
they've seen the botched russian
offensive in the north of the country
down here where i am in the donbass
they're also familiar with this enemy
they're familiar with the tactics this
is a war that remember has been uh
running now one way or another since
2014 so for eight years but of course
the big big fear is for people still
trapped uh where i am and it seems that
the russian forces are trying to
encircle the donbass in a kind of pincer
movement to cut off ukrainian forces
these are some of the most skilled and
experienced uh ukrainian soldiers but
there are quite a few civilians still
trapped here and the fear of course is
that they will get caught in the
crossfire of this fighting
alex you and the team keep the head down
for now thanks very much indeed
a political correspondent to marco and
he's here on a related topic let's trust
the foreign secretary making an
important speech tonight one of the
takeaways from that which i've read is
once again we are hearing senior
politicians within the government
re-emphasizing the fact this is not
coming to an end any time soon that is
absolutely her message this is a mansion
house speech that she's giving tonight
in the centre of london and saying that
if ukraine is to win and she calls that
a strategic imperative for us all then
the west needs a far tougher approach
and she sets out three ways of doing
that one more defense spending she says
the two percent of gdp targets should be
a floor not a ceiling although of course
the government recently decided not to
spend any more in its budget the second
part is cutting off russian oil and gas
once and for all and the third is of
course deepening relationships with
other democracies but liz trust will be
warning that this is a long haul i'll
read you a bit of what she's going to be
saying in this speech
she says we need a new approach one that
melds hard security and economic
security builds stronger global
alliances and where free nations are
more assertive and self-confident
one that recognises we're seeing the
return of geopolitics we cannot be
complacent the fate of ukraine remains
in the balance and let's be clear if
putin succeeds there will be untold
further misery across europe and
terrible consequences across the globe
we would never feel safe again so we
must be prepared for the long haul and
double down on our support for ukraine
heavy weapons tanks aeroplanes digging
deep into our inventories ramping up
production we need to do all of this
you'll notice you talked about
aeroplanes of course that's something
ukraine has repeatedly asked for they
want warplanes to try and bomb some of
the russian weaponry the problem has
been that they have to come from
neighbouring countries and they don't
want to take that risk
of escalating the conflict if that were
to happen if they were to make that come
off then of course the levels of
confrontation with russia would ratchet
up considerably tomorrow for now thanks
very much indeed uh plenty more of
course on ukraine throughout the
programme but let's turn our attention
to this story police are searching for
missing mother of two katie kenyon and
have arrested a man on suspicion of
murder this guy's fraser mod is in
burnley for us this morning with the
latest fraser good to see you and not
what anyone wanted to hear from the
police this now a murder investigation
well the
search will continue
today the police yesterday announced
that the 50 year old man that they had
arrested initially on suspicion of
kidnap had been re-arrested on suspicion
of murder and of course that will have
come as a devastating blow to katy
kenyon's family there was a statement
issued yesterday evening from lancashire
police's head of major crime saying
while i hold some slim hope that katie
may still be found alive i'm sad to say
that katie has now been missing for over
four days despite extensive police
inquiries and appeals we have not found
katie nor have there been any sightings
of katie he goes on to say we've spoken
to katie's family and they are
understandably extremely upset by this
latest development and i have officers
continuing to offer them support my
thoughts are with them
at this time so this is now a murder
investigation there have been some 60
people assisting in the search for katy
in this area around gisborne woods it's
a huge area for them to search it's
around 3 000 acres over four and a half
square miles of densely wooded area that
they that they are searching at the
moment 60 people taking part in that
search they've had aerial support the
support from
police forces from wales from merseyside
uh from lancashire and from greater
manchester police as well as the bowling
mountain rescue team dog teams have been
in the area as well casualty dogs uh
trying to find any trace of katie and uh
as the police say that uh it seems now
that their belief is that the hopes are
now fading of finding katie alive
although
her family will still be clinging on to
the fact that the police say they're
they believe there is still a slim
chance uh that she could be found alive
but these uh this is an extremely
difficult uh type of terrain to search
the the area that is in question here a
huge area densely wooded as i say and in
part in the past 15 years or so there's
been a couple of previous searches by
police in areas similar to this
and they have taken days weeks even
months and in on occasion have not been
successful at all so this this is a very
difficult task facing the police they
are still questioning a 50 year old man
who's been arrested on suspicion of
murder and it would seem that any hope
of finding katie quickly may well rest
on on their questioning of that man and
whether he is unable or unwilling to
give them any further information as to
where she might be
fraser back to you just as soon as there
is any news there for now thanks very
much indeed
let's get more reaction to the latest
developments in ukraine and indeed the
policy announcement on his own brief uh
the justice secretary deputy prime
minister dominic rabb joins us on in the
studio good to see you this morning mr
good morning and i i i do promise we
will get to your brief in a few minutes
time but there's an awful lot around
ukraine we need to discuss we
we heard yesterday the us uh secretary
of defense lloyd austin saying that
ukraine believes it can win the war
we've just been speaking to our
correspondent in the donbass saying that
forces there believe they can win the
war boris johnson when he was in india
struck a note of caution suggesting that
russia might win is are we the voice of
reason in all of this or or perhaps is
boris johnson just parking some of the
boosterism when it comes to ukraine well
i think we want to show maximum
solidarity to ukraine but it's clear
that the conflict is in the balance
i've said since the first time i came on
sky news i didn't think it would be over
in weeks possibly not even in months so
we need the strategic stamina and
staying power and i think the prime
minister is very conscious of that so we
keep ramping up the pressure on putin
through the sanctions we keep supporting
as best we can with military hardware
and others support the ukrainians and we
do the most we can to deter
putin's behavior i spoke to the icc
prosecutor yesterday we're rallying
countries to support the investigation
not just because we want to see justice
done for any war crimes we want to send
a deterrent message now to those
commanders in the field that if they
commit war crimes they'll end up behind
bars but just to pick up on something as
you yourself admit you've said before
not over in weeks and months you know we
could potentially be looking in into the
years certainly over 12 months in terms
of her involvement let's trust your
colleague of foreign secretaries is
making a really important speech later
on today in which she's going to suggest
that that two percent nato spending
target or on defense
should be the floor not the ceiling i
mean just in terms of the length of the
mission with our current spending how
sustainable is it for the uk and other
nations to keep sending arms with the
temple that we already have well that's
why we need the strategic stamina we're
one of the few countries that meets the
nato
target and i think there's long been
this argument and you've heard it from
successive american administrations that
some european countries need to step up
to the plate we agree with that
and at the same time we need to think uh
if this is going to last months possibly
years how we keep supporting at the
right pace the ukrainian resistance
which has been so sorry to interrupt but
it sounds like you kind of agree with
liz trust i mean when she refers to two
percent as as the floor not the ceiling
certainly suggests that liz truss is
minded to see a significant increase in
defense spending here
and that view is not universally held
around the cabinet table as i understand
it well no we've seen a massive increase
in defense spending
the chancellor
and the defense sector work very closely
under the leadership of the prime
minister on that obviously we've got a
cost of living crisis we need to cut our
coats according to our cloth overall but
actually the direction of travel has
been to boost
and change the nature of our defenses
because of course and you can see this
in ukraine you can see this in terms of
russia as an adversary it's not just
conventional warfare we're seeing we've
also got cyber misinformation we need to
adapt to that that's exactly what the
chancellor and defense secretary have
done the chancellor didn't do it the
last opportunity that he did have did he
in the spring statement not by my record
no no but we just had a spending review
we had a strategic
defense uh review uh an integrated
review in foreign policy that was
absolutely the right time to take a
long-term forward look and the chance
that absolutely along with the defense
secretary addressed this there just in
terms though of of what we are hearing
from the russians
by my measure i think this is the first
time that russia has made a a direct
threat against the united kingdom
yesterday james heap
your colleague at the mod said it was
completely legitimate for ukraine to
seek out russian targets to disrupt
their logistics the russians have
responded saying well if you do that if
you keep encouraging them you know
become a legitimate target what do you
feel about that well the russian
statement is unlawful and what we're
doing is lawful international law is
very clear on this we're entitled all
states are entitled to provide military
support to any state exercising the
right of lawful defense against an
aggressive invasion and frankly if
russia starts threatening other
countries it only adds
further to their pariah status and will
only further the if you like solidarity
and the consensus of the international
community that they must be stopped just
basically you can we've heard this
morning poland has had the gas cut off
we would assume therefore that bulgaria
will will follow quickly it will just
quickly follow suit what can we do to
assist them because it does look like
poland is going to be in an awful lot of
trouble without that kind of energy well
i mean first of all we need to show
solidarity clearly what we are seeing is
the need to wean ourselves off uh
reliance on russia we've obviously got
very low reliance on gas from russia i
think it's around three percent uh
though some european countries in a
different position we have been warning
about this for a while but yes we'll
stand
shoulder to shoulder with our polish
friends and allies they've said that
they can deal with this but of course it
will have a a delete a very damaging
effect on russia as well because it is
becoming further and further more and
more not just a political prayer but an
economic prior and that will put the
squeeze ultimately on vladimir putin but
one thing is true and clear we can't
allow his bullying behavior whether it's
economic warfare
or its military warfare to succeed can
we just briefly then to return to the to
the mail on sunday article um about
angela raynor yeah we understand that
the whips have been taking a look into
all of this i mean here's the the the
piece itself i mean i don't i probably
don't even need to ask what your
response is to the piece itself i think
i probably know but it's terrible and uh
i i go up occasionally against angela
rainer in my position as deputy prime
minister she's a formidable opponent i
respect her entirely and i can't stand
this kind of thing so has that have the
whips gotten anywhere closer to who was
responsible for all of this well i i i'd
need to speak to the chief whip about
this is something that he will be
looking at and of course it's very
difficult to find but what we're clear
is that we don't tolerate um we will not
tolerate any behavior and uh
smear like this and if we can find out
we will take action against it i i
wonder what you make of the the editor
of the mail on sunday's refusal to
attend that meeting he was invited by
the speaker of the house of commons
and the daily mail today being being
rather punchy i have to say about it no
mr speaker they're invoking the freedom
of the press i suppose the other view in
all of this is what was to be lost by
turning up
at the speaker's office and having a
conversation about this look i think
whether it's the speaker or the the
newspaper editors we all believe in two
things one the power and the importance
of free speech but secondly the
importance of not allowing that to be
abused and uh and used to spread sexism
in any shape or form
i'm not going to second guess the the
the decision makers by decisions of
editors it's his current common speaker
should the common speaker then have
invited i think it was a legitimate
thing for lindsay hall do to invite him
and of course it's the prerogative of
any editor to decide how they treat that
invitation um everyone yesterday at
cabinet was asked to come up with some
bright ideas for the cost of living
crisis i'm just wondering what yours
were sitting at the at the head of the
justice department we look at um i don't
comment on the detail of what we discuss
in cabinet but i think there's a whole
range of things that we're looking at
first of all we've got a 22 billion
pound package to deal with the cost of
living but this prime minister and this
chance are going to be absolutely
assiduous and relentless in looking at
what more we can do we're providing
rebates on uh council tax on energy
bills we've got this pot of money that
local authorities can use to target the
most vulnerable um but we look as is
well known we discussed child care one
of the things there's lots of former
housing ministers around the cabinet
table we've discussed housing costs
these are all areas where we're never
going to stop we're going to continue
unflinchingly to look at what more we
can do and the reason being is we
understand the pressure that families up
and down the country are they do you
understand the kind of the knee-jerk
response when you know the papers are
carrying stories that grant chap's big
bright idea was you know making annual
mot test come you know biannually you
know torsten bell from the resolution
foundation says if this is the answer
then the government has lost the plot i
suppose the problem for you is if you
have all these individual policies and
you bring them together and you total
them up then eventually it may well be
that we see that the cost of living
crisis ameliorated somewhat but there's
no one big measure like the labour party
has the windfall tax which would see an
immediate kind of cash injection first
of all i don't agree in terms of the
characterization the conservative
policies the uc taper saves the relevant
families a thousand pounds a year um if
you look at what we've done on the
national living wage that saves a
thousand pounds a year for those
eligible full-time workers and frankly
if you look at labour's policy you asked
about it of a windfall tax that would uh
damage investment in energy supplies we
need and hike bills it's disastrous it's
not serious so what this shows is
they're coming up with frankly
ill thought through policies but we have
got a plan a concerted plan and i think
that's what voters want to see uh
minister i am nothing if not a man of
your word so let's talk about europe and
and one has to say a fairly significant
announcement about the way we tackle
radicalization within our prisons tell
us more so look the the changing threat
from terrorism uh evolves all the time
but it's also evolving in prisons why
because we're locking up more terrorists
and extremists than ever before 200
convicted prisoners convicted of
terrorist offences another 200 prisoners
who've got terrorist links jonathan hall
has conducted this independent report we
accept it pretty much in full
and we got to do more to prevent
extremists tainting the well let me give
you two brief illustrations one we must
nip in the bud far earlier the kind of
coercive controlling behavior by
extremists which can lead to
radicalization and terrorism just to
give a concrete example of course we
want to respect the right for prisoners
to be able to eat halal prepare food
allow but they can't have no-go areas in
kitchens for those who don't respect or
or comply with their rules secondly
we've got these separation centers which
are used to isolate the most dangerous
radicalizing recruiters of uh
of terrorists we need to probably make
greater use of that so i'm beefing up
the money to target those offenders who
need to be removed and finally we'll
need this bill of rights to replace the
human rights act to stop the legal
attrition that we're already starting to
see with terrorists and extremists
claiming a right to socialize within
prison when what actually they want to
do is radicalize it sounds to me that
that last part is the most important
part in all of this if the kind of the
mantra that we hear from government
about activist lawyers is is true and
you would certainly expect when you
start bringing in some of these changes
for there to be challenges all the way
to the supreme court well we've already
had it we've got a number of cases uh
we've had to it's cost us half a million
pounds uh to defend these cases we've
not been taken to court yet uh but what
i want to do is is put the policies in
place to protect the public i think we
have allowed understandable uh cultural
and religious sensitivities to deter us
as jonathan hall sets out and of course
what the bill of rights will do is while
respecting our fundamental freedoms make
sure we've got the common sense balance
and in this context allowing prison
governors to take the action they need
to retain the security in the prison but
also to protect the public from these
very dangerous people
great to have you in the studio thank
you
should we have a quick look at the
papers and of course plenty about
ukraine and there
russia has threatened strikes against
western targets uh that's the lead in
the times it says the kremlin is ready
to retaliate
after remarks by the uk's armed forces
minister that ukraine attacking targets
in russia was completely legitimate
crunch time
in the crunch time uk that's the lead
story in the metro it reports that most
people are
already cutting back on spending and
dipping into their savings as the cost
of living crisis bites
meanwhile the eye says solutions being
considered including as discussed with
mr rabb the annual mot test on cars and
cutting the cost of child care
now the outstanding leader of myanmar
onsang su chi has been sentenced to
another five years in prison by the
military let's speak now disguise
correspondent tom cheshire who has more
on this tom explain exactly what is
going on here
we we've known that the military
government there has had it in for on
such for quite some time
yeah even before she was elected
as leader democratically elected as
leader of myanmar
she spent a long time under house arrest
now since the military overthrew that
government in february last year she has
been detained she's faced a series of
trials the ones before this were less
serious there over possessing
walkie-talkies and breaking kobe
regulations they still handed her a
six-year sentence for that for that but
this was a corruption case the first of
ten charges she faces and they found her
guilty of that and sentenced her today
to five years in prison now her lawyers
haven't been able to speak to the media
this trial has been held behind closed
doors so her opponent sorry her
supporters will say this is a determined
effort to keep her away from politics
yet again this sentence means she won't
be able to run
in the elections that the military
promise will happen uh by the end of
next year and she faces a further 10
corruption charges which could see her
spend the rest of her life she's 76 in
prison and she's not the only one facing
these sorts of cases members of a party
have also been arrested more than
thirteen thousand people are detained in
myanmar according to human rights groups
so that shows uh what looks like a
concerted effort by the military to keep
its hold on power but at the same time
those sorts of numbers suggest the scale
of the opposition they are still facing
uh in myanmar there is a lot of
opposition sometimes military conflict
throughout the country
tom for now many thanks indeed
still to come on the programme p and o
have set sail again from dover this
morning uh but i'll be speaking to the
national secretary of the rmt union dan
proctor about that a ship that stalled
yesterday
[Music]
welcome back and remind our as to our
top stories and the justice secretary
dominic robins told the programme that
russia's threat of an immediate
proportionate response to what it calls
the uk's provocation of ukraine is
unlawful and would add to its pariah
status
russian gas supplies to poland have
resumed again this morning after they
were cut off because
poland refused to pay in rubles
and mot's could be asked as part of
government plans to tackle the cost of
living crisis
i will in the last few minutes dominic
rabb told me the uk will stand shoulder
to shoulder with countries like poland
and bulgaria who've been threatened by
russia
he also condemned statements that russia
has made about the uk as unlawful
international law is very clear on this
we're entitled all states are entitled
to provide military support to any state
exercising the right of lawful defense
against an aggressive invasion and
frankly if russia starts threatening
other countries it only adds
further to their pariah status and will
only further the if you like solidarity
and the consensus of the international
community that they must be stopped
tamara back with us um tell us more
about the interview with dominic grab
what did you make of it so this is on
the point that liz trust will be making
this big speech tonight about how we
need to send heavier weaponry including
tanks and warplanes to ukraine and even
with that it could still be a very long
haul for ukraine to actually triumph in
this conflict he was saying first of all
that if
this whole idea of sending tanks and
warplanes has been discussed a lot and
not come off because they have to come
from the neighboring countries who have
the soviet-era tanks and war planes that
ukraine wants and then back filled by
western countries giving probably poland
some of those tanks and warplanes and
they haven't wanted to take the risk
because it would have to be a unilateral
decision it couldn't be a nato decision
and so he says that this you know if
russia was to threaten a country which
did that then you know the west would
come to their age but clearly whatever
guarantees were needed in that situation
haven't been there as yet but he sounded
and liz trust sounds hopeful that it
could happen down the line as to defense
spending here he says the uk is one of
the few countries that meets the two
percent target but she's saying that
that should be a flaw and not a ceiling
and i think there's an interesting
cabinet division on this liz trust
clearly pushing for far more defense
spending than we have at the moment but
others notably the chancellor not doing
that last month in the budget because of
course you spend more on defense you
have to spend less elsewhere and there
are of course huge other priorities
after covert not least the nhs and
getting through the backlog yeah a lot
on his plate as well tomorrow for now
thanks very much indeed
ah now the first piano freight ferry has
left the port of dover to cali since the
company stacked 800 workers and replaced
them with cheaper agency staff
joining us now darren proctor national
secretary of the rail maritime and
transport workers union uh darren good
to see you this morning i hope you're
well and i just wonder if we can start
with of course p and o and the ferry
sailing yesterday i saw you quoted this
morning in the papers what's your
understanding as to exactly what went
wrong
my understanding is that the vessel was
part way across from
point a to point b
and the the engines
failed uh that there was a blackout on
board the vessel and it was left you
know just floating about in the seat for
two hours there was the stash calls put
out art and eli were called to the
vessel there was uh the queen victoria
uh we were standing by on for assistance
and he was talk there and this is
exactly what we said would happen uh
when you sat here your entire workforce
you're getting rid of
uh the skills the knowledge the
experience on board those vessels and
seafarers can go from one vessel to
another but knowing the intricacies and
being familiar with with the you know
the operation on boards with the
technical aspects of the job and this
was clearly something that was
demonstrated yesterday when a problem
arose they didn't know how to deal with
it
i mean dan from what you're saying and
given the inexperience of these staff i
mean are you saying it's a matter of
when and not if we see further problems
with another piano ferry
100 i've said this week that you know
there's gonna be blood on the hands of
those individuals that allow these
vessels to sail and at some point going
forward all the interviews that we've
given over the last four weeks in
relation to safety will be used in some
form of an investigation and we want a
proactive approach to safety we've
identified that there's problems
individuals working on border vessel for
12 hours a day seven days a week for 17
weeks they're not going to be uh
you know of the mindset that they should
be or that they would be in week one or
week two
and and when you're bringing individuals
in who don't know the systems
you know when a seafarer joins a vessel
particularly in the engine room they
would start off at the lower grades they
would have the experience to to rely
upon of the senior individuals they
would become familiarized with all the
various systems on board and you know
i've heard people say that it's a
coincidence and blackouts happen
blackouts do happen but very very
directified very very quickly and i
spoke to some of my colleagues on social
media last night you know
you know seafarers and i asked them to
give me some examples of timelines and
they said to me you know one individual
we've been at sea 50 years he's blacked
out he thinks six times and it was put
back on no more than 30 seconds later
here we have a vessel you know aimlessly
drifting for two hours
where are we then darren as regards the
the 800 staff that were similarly um
sacked by piando i remember grant chaps
that the transport secretary on this
program and others talking a very good
game about how they would the government
would be holding piano to account for
all of this is that transparent
no it's not sensed by it they've talked
a very good game it's become a little
bit more not more than a waffle shot to
be honest you know when we want them to
step up they're talking about bringing
in a a fair fetish framework that will
ensure that the ferry sector in the uk
will have decent employment safe jobs
quality jobs but we've not yet seen that
all we've seen is the nine-point plan
being rolled up and nothing more since
then you know so we you know we're
calling on them to you know we want
actions not words
um you know um
hopefully they'll see something this
week but you know we'll continue to
demonstrate and if we need to you know
roll further out then demonstrations to
other ports then we will
when piano ferries say that their
business model doesn't work if they
continue to employ people on the same
conditions that that they had previously
what is your response to that
well you look at other ferry operators
in the uk and you have to ask yourself
why they are able to operate and you
have to look at the amount of directors
the amount of management that they have
in place they should knock down to the
seafarers
um you know so there's there's good
operators in this country who are able
to run and pay decent wages to ukc fares
and operate vessels safely this has been
you know mismanagement over a number of
years we've questioned piano going back
a number of years what is their mark and
what is their target audience because
we've seen that their
uh
their market if you like particularly in
hull where they were offering passengers
a ticket for two nights accommodation on
board for 35 pounds and that can't be
sustained so you have to look at what
they've done in terms of the
marketability of piano ferries as
opposed to blaming the seafarers and
cutting their jobs for systematic
failures at management level
dan proctor from the rmt good to see you
this morning thanks very much for
joining us
now a clinical psychologist has
diagnosed amber hard with borderline
personality disorder in day 9 of the
ongoing definition trial with johnny
depp mr depp is suing his ex-wife for
libel over a 2018 article she wrote in
the washington post alleging she was
physically and sexually abused she is
counter-suing our correspondent shingi
maruriki reports
johnny depp and amber heard once walked
down the aisle together but they're now
facing off in court in a real-life
hollywood legal drama
they're pursuing her for 50 million
dollars for a 2018 opinion piece she
wrote about domestic violence which
actually doesn't mention the actor
she's counter-suing for 100 million
dollars and yesterday the court heard
more about their disputes
one of which was seen firsthand by the
estate manager of depth private island
who spoke via video call you could hear
inside the house
yelling
um
her amber yelling and and johnny
answering back and you could really hear
what was being said amber was telling
him that he was a
washed up actor um he was gonna die a
lonely uh fat lonely old man
the spotlight then shifted to herd's
mental state a depth witness concluded
she had multiple personality disorders
traits she said often spiral into
attempts to avoid being abandoned the
results of ms heard's evaluation
supported two diagnoses borderline
personality disorder and histrionic
personality disorder she also cast doubt
on herd's claim she suffered ptsd
symptoms the actress maintains are
caused by her relationship with depp i
very specifically um was assessing to
determine whether post-traumatic stress
disorder was present and it was not
we've heard from depp and an array of
witnesses but heard has not had her
chance to respond
she's set to testify later in the trial
shinki marike sky news
coming up after the break i'll be
looking ahead to the foreign secretary's
keynote speech on global security with
the chair of the commons defense select
committee to buy us out after this
welcome back a little later today the
foreign secretary liz truss will call
for a reboot of the world's approach to
tackling russian acts of aggression
such as we've seen in ukraine well let's
take you through the latest activity on
the ground there it's estimated that two
thousand troops and one thousand
civilians are still holed up in bunkers
underneath the as of style steel works
in mario paul
within the past four 24 hours in
transnistria a breakaway region of
moldova beside the ukrainian border
several explosions believed caused by
rocket propelled grenades hit the
territories ministry of state security
well yesterday russia intensified its
aerial attacks on eastern ukraine as it
continues its refocused campaign to take
over the donbass region moscow claims to
have hit dozens of military targets in
the area
uh joining us now the chair of the
commons defense select committee tobacco
mr edwards good to have you on the
programme again
um
liz trust is set to argue for a reboot
in global security today what needs to
be changed what needs to improve
well i'm really pleased to see uh
britain in this tradition of playing a
role on the international stage leaning
into this because the state of our
international institutions
is dire they have served us well since
their creation after the second world
war but they're no longer able to hold
current nations to account the united
nations for example the security council
is paralyzed because of that veto that
china and russia exploits on a regular
basis so indeed their weakness uh is
actually being taken advantage of by
russia and china and so i want to see
britain play an important role in their
upgrade in advancing um what these
international institutions do
particularly the world trade
organization as well but the second
aspect is also i hope that she'll focus
on is asking ourselves what are we
trying to achieve uh in ukraine uh this
uh uh conflict is continuing to to drag
on as such we're pouring more weapons
systems in uh quality and quantity is
going up but to what end the unanswered
question i hope the foreign secretary
will address is what are we collectively
trying to achieve what is mission
success given the threat from putin is
not just in ukraine but well beyond that
that is game changing uh what we're
experiencing here in european security
putin must strategically fail in ukraine
and if we allow him to survive he will
regroup an attempt to advance his sphere
of influence way beyond ukraine in the
future so we need to be very very clear
what our mission is it must be to push
russia completely out of the donbass
region that for me is what success looks
like it defines our overall strategy
then determines the tactics and then of
course the subsequent weapon systems and
training that never needed to come into
play that starts to look like a plan
given the scale of russian forces though
given the the the furious fighting that
we have seen in in the east of the
country if the ukraine if ukraine is to
win in the donbass it's not going to
happen in the next couple of weeks is it
it will require a sustained effort from
the west
and liz trustee's comments about you
know other nato member countries perhaps
upping their contributions to defence
spending and hitting that two percent
target you can kind of see where she's
going with that argument
i can and this is required why we
require international statecraft we need
to coordinate the activities the might
of nato is far more formidable than the
russian forces itself we are now
involved in a proxy war we can't uh deny
that i am concerned by general mark
milley the chair of the u.s joint chiefs
of staff who said uh gave an ominous
warning
yesterday to say time is not on
ukraine's side the outcome of the battle
uh is that will be determined by western
support given to ukraine so we need to
look carefully at what we can do to
upgrade our support for ukraine so they
can push back russian forces out of the
entire donbass region
speaking very specifically though about
the uk currently defense spending
between i think 2.1 to 2.3 of gdp i mean
is there not an argument for the united
kingdom reinvesting in its military
reinvesting significant in its military
perhaps pushing up to a closer to three
percent
i think i've made this point on your
program many times that we are still on
a peacetime budget setting of around two
percent but look what we're doing quite
rightly supporting ukraine uh with
training now with taskings and personnel
involved in europe that were never
planned for these threats were i think
acknowledged that they were coming over
the horizon they have now landed and as
i say this is a turning point in
european security we need to recognize
and i hear this call but other
departments will say no no no i need
money as well but if you don't look
after your security you then become
vulnerable our economy becomes
vulnerable and prosperity is affected
and then there's no money for any of the
departments let alone defense it's
important that the treasury number 10
recognizes we don't not only need to
improve our statecraft to match you know
the cold war settings uh in our
confidence in standing up to russia but
also our armed forces our security our
entire defense posture needs to improve
up mr before we let you go perhaps just
a word on the possible accession of
finland to nato plenty people can
understand the rationale for it
particularly if you're living in finland
right now but we do know that there will
be according to the russians a
proportionate response which to my eyes
means military buildup in that
particular part of the world how
sanguine are you about that well we need
to be i think distance ourselves from
the uh the rhetoric that comes out of
the kremlin which is designed to scare
us designed to spook us designed to make
us think
again
nato is very much a defensive alliance
if finland phil threatened if the people
in finland want to join nato that is
their right and absolutely it would be
important for nato to include them in
this alliance it will i think almost
double the actual border line between
nato and russia itself that is something
that russia will have to come to terms
with but we shouldn't uh proceed to
russian aggression and allow russia to
exploit our weakness this which is
exactly what putin has been doing
tobias elwood great to have you on the
program this morning really appreciate
your time
thank you thank you
let's continue to monitor events in
ukraine some debate about what is
happening with russia's gas supply to
both poland and bulgaria the the latest
that we know is it has at least been
shut off for a time we'll continue to
monitor events there but we will be back
to our correspondence in and around
ukraine particularly at those in the
donbass we've seen the violence we'll
bring it to you next
[Music]